[Music]
good evening mrs cooper
can i speak to sheldon no you can't
speak to sheldon it's late he's in bed
oh i was hoping he might like to go to a
party with me has everyone lost their
mind he's a little boy tam
good night good lord
that mouth of yours is a machine gun
[Music]
tonight
what are you doing trying to calculate
the odds of the dolphins covering the
spread next sunday
i like dolphins they talk out of that
hole in their head
hello tam
what are you doing here would you like
to go to a party with me
i don't want to go to a party with
anyone i would
please sheldon it's right across the
street just get me in and you can go
back to bed
i have to ask my mom no need she knows
all about the party
all right then i need a minute to change
why are you wearing that it makes me
look harder
just so we're clear once you get in i'm
going home
hey charlotte what are you doing hey
everybody check it out shelton's here
i hope that doesn't wake up the kids
should i go over here and say something
i think you should
i was bluffing don't make me put my
socks back on
never mind good night
good night
i feel bad about yelling at georgie
yeah he deserved it you should do it
more
i think he's feeling left out now that
you and sheldon are spending so much
time together
are you kidding me you're always saying
to find something in common with sheldon
and now that i have you're telling me
i'm ignoring georgie i'm not saying that
i'm just reminding you that you got two
sons
i know i also got a daughter i need to
spend more time with
you do but i wouldn't worry about her
she's an angel
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing here
hello georgie you're not supposed to be
here
neither are you you're grounded
come on both of you are going home
but now what happened how's puberty
treating you because it is knocking me
for a loop
[Applause]
[Music]
right
you